with that pattern you could actually go
and and fly to the moon because they're
the patterns that are interesting I was
floored by how impressed people were at
my skills when I went to they went to
the u.s. to work in the Napa Valley for
the wine stuff when I felt like the
dumbest person in my math class at uni
because i was with the smartest guys in
like victoria and and i felt dumb but I
wasn't done and you know I mean and it's
like and it's like you would you could
run rings around them with I don't know
how much maths you've done but it's like
it's just this it's it's this it's the
having the right attitude having the
right approach and going I don't know
the answer but leave it with me I gotta
work yeah yeah well you talk to people
you know how to talk you know how to
work things out yeah it's just really
really important and these are skills
that you you need to you need to learn
but the thing is is that that it's kind
of like it just has the hardest part is
kind of getting started getting that
inertia but once you start learning
something like I was I surprised myself
and having to learn something that I
thought I couldn't learn mathematically
because I've done so much mats it's like
I actually kind of worked out oh I see
how these things something else so you
gathered a bit of momentum and from
there when I learned I might how to see
where you can get is right
yes it's kind of like an athletics as
well as like like a really good rugby
player and ever or a football they learn
certain you know they learn the skills
but then it's like okay we're going to
try doing something else and they will
know we'll be able to adapt Lee well
then you meet those people who are
they've picked that up and then they can
just walk into any sport yeah and they
can learn this very true skill it's very
good fit that yeah almost automatically
yeah and they know they kind of know and
there's a reason why I bring this up is
because I want people to understand that
there are parallels in in the world that
people understand and think that is real
world you know there's a real world you
know this is a competition between
sports people and it's real this is real
life and death I'm going to learn and
we're going to we gotta focus and we're
gonna you know it comes down to the
smallest abut when you think of when you
think about a sports match I mean you
know even like the finals I mean they
are so evenly matched usually and it
comes down to sometimes points these
determine the time very largest people
go oh we are the champions and we're the
losers it's like everyone's a winner you
know it is like so you're more amazing I
can't
I can't do when you do the comparison
there's just this particular thing went
that way instead of yes and sometimes
it's it's about those majors but that's
what people say and so yet so so the
other the other point I want two
dimensionless as well as like in terms
of patterns that mean something I got
asked by journalists on the twelfth of
the twelve of the twelfth what the
significance of that was and it was like
what does that mean and it's like well
the way that we've cut up a time in the
way we've done it is that we do 12
months really would make sense to have
13 months in having four weeks each
which will be perfect in any way may 12
months and it's the twelfth day and it's
the twelfth year but not really its 2012
and not really if you ask you know
someone like a Jewish personal to you
someone to measure my knees or like you
know Islam or whatever it's like all
these different religions have different
ways but anyway that is it's an
arbitrary thing but I tell you what if
you um if you drop a ball if you drop a
ball at different heights and you you
measure the time than it takes for that
ball to drop okay and if you if you
measure that out and do it you'll
actually be able to draw a line through
that and you'll get a pattern and with
that pattern you could actually go and
and fly to the movies there the patterns
that are interesting and they're not
they're not because someone said oh
that's dice up time like this exactly
they're just true and they're discovered
and then you can different so that in so
what's really interesting is like
getting scare gets cultural attention 12
12 12 but what's going on is they it's
great because you're recognizing a pen
you're seeing a pattern there it's like
but don't stop there because that
pattern is meaningless it's meaningless
it doesn't matter 1111 what who cares it
doesn't matter but look at that look at
this
there's pattern in nature look at this
pattern of what we can learn from it and
that's exactly what's happened and so
we're being lit by artificial lights you
know to a greater extent like with this
got a building around us and it's not
killing us it's because people have
thought about stuff and patterns and
forces and then worked out stuff and it
only worked because there's patterns if
there was if things were chaotic me and
you would not look like this we would be
foraging around the ground we'd be
animals still but there to be total
chaos it's been taking advantage of
exactly happen mr. Sutton's yeah that's
where we are so I'm being like totally
like you know 2001 epic about it but it
comes down to your life it comes down to
your life and there are patterns that
you can draw and and we do it all the
time you know what people people will
see an opportunity in the business
market you know they'll go I know what I
can do I see this thing happening
overseas I'm going to bring it here it
seemed very real world it's got
financial things but but what to make
these things work you have to be able to
think abstractly you have to think that
the manpower and that's why problem
solving is so important and in my shows
I'm just trying to have fun with it
because that's another way of getting
people to see it in a different way so
to try and drills all the way back no
reason why I'm here is because I really
want to I can I've been able to work out
how to make people laugh which is why
which is why you know it gets people
attention because people get a payoff
for it but yeah but that's part of them
that's hopefully it's part of I've been
able to explain it in kind of rambling
way now would you been you've been
really generous with your time I think
if people wanted to know a bit more
about about what you do yes or get in
contact with you how do they do that hi
well you can go to my website www you
can see my work on numberphile which i
think is fantastic just put numberphile
in to youtube and if you don't know what
YouTube is this to put that into Google
and if you don't know what Google is I
know it go on to yahoo let's take a
google into yahoo if it's still around
yeah do a 0 l but but yeah I'm available
to do what to do work and shows I think
and getting pretty busy but anyway but
it's been great so this has been an
incredible show thank you very much it
Horace she's so